so adam warlock is someone that we've
been looking at joining the mcu since
like the first guardians movie right
right and like the
speculation about who would play adam
warlock whatever but here you are
and everyone's obsessed
that's very good
but like what i mean what is your
reaction to the fan reaction about you
like it's overwhelmingly positive oh man
it's been lovely i mean like you know i
know people rightly so hold strong
opinions over these sort of decisions
and you know they hold the character
close to their heart so i really hope i
can do it justice you know to the best
of my abilities super grateful to have
had the opportunity um really don't take
the fans kind of passion for for granted
and uh you know if the reaction is
positive i'm very grateful for that i
just hope i don't let people down
guardians has been such a linchpin of
the mcu one of the real highlights that
people love about it what's it been like
working with this cast cause it just
seems like a party all the time oh man
the cast is so amazing you know and
really james you know as the kind of
like leader really kind of cultivates a
really lovely atmosphere on set a real
genuine camaraderie between everybody
and you know these folks are tightly
knit and have known each other for a
long time and coming into that i was a
little intimidated they couldn't have
made me feel like more at home and more
welcome and super grateful for that dude
i'm so excited for the film
congratulations thank you man yeah good
to see you cheers
you